PROFESSOR: So now we're
going to see if we
can apply what we just
learned about elasticity
and how to measure it
by cooking a steak.
We're then going to measure the
elasticity of a raw piece of steak
and a piece of steak that is cooked
to about well or medium well,
and we're going to see how
the elasticity of the steak
changes as the steak cooks.
We have a steak here.
And in order to do this scientifically,
we have cut out little pieces of steak
and they're all the same
dimensions, so they're
four centimeters by four centimeters.
And we're going to apply a weight to the
steaks before and after they're cooked,
and we're going to see
how much they compress.
And then we're going to use
the equation of the week
and see if we can
calculate the elasticity.
OK, so here's our little setup
for how to measure elasticity.
Very simple.
You can even set this
up in your own kitchen.
So we have a plastic
plate that we're going
to place on top of the piece of
food, and then we have a ruler,
and then we have a weight.
And here I'm showing
you a 200 gram weight
that we're just going to
place on top of the steak.
And as you can see, the initial
measurement for this is 30 millimeters.
And it's a little bit
hard to see, but then
as we apply the weight,
the 200 gram weight,
the measurement goes
down to 26 millimeters.
So there is a compression
of four millimeters.
So now what we can do
is take these numbers
and plug them into the
equation of the week
and see what we get for elasticity.
So we know that elasticity
is stress over strain,
and stress is the force over the area.
And we already know what the
area is because I told you
that each side of the steak is four
centimeters by four centimeters,
so that's 16 centimeters squared.
And the force is the mass times
the gravitational constant.
So the mass is 200 grams,
that's 0.2 kilograms,
times 10 meters per second squared.
OK.
And for our strain, we have the
delta L, the difference that we got,
which was four millimeters,
over the initial height.
So that is four millimeters
over 30 millimeters.
So for now, just plug all of this in.
This is two Newtons over
16 centimeters squared,
and 16 centimeters squared
is 0.0016 meters squared,
so we need to make sure we
go back to the SI units.
And then we divide this with
four over 30 millimeters.
And so this turns out to be
9,400 Newtons per meter squared.
So this is our elastic
modulus for a raw steak.
Now let's go and do this for a cooked
steak, which Daniel has cooked for us.
So here we now have a
cooked piece of steak
and it's been cooked
to about medium well.
And the force is still the same.
It's 200 grams times the gravitational
constant, so it's two newtons.
And the area is the same, it's four
centimeters times four centimeters.
And as we apply the weight,
you can see how the steak
has compressed to 28 millimeters.
So there's a change and there's
a compression of two millimeters,
so about half as much as
you saw in the raw steak.
So now let's plug this
into the equation.
And so this turns out to be
18,700 Newtons per meter squared.
So this is about twice the elastic
modulus as we saw for the raw steak.
So the steak has actually become
stiffer as we cooked the steak.